all right everybody
we are live
so so today was a very strange day for
me
um basically um my cousin who is also
possibly my best friend i would say
passed away this morning from
an aggressive pancreatic cancer
and everything happened very fast you
know he was one of the strongest people
that i know
he was training for hours every day he
was doing iron man competitions
and then um in during covid all of a
sudden he started having weird symptoms
and uh within a few months he was dead
and so i saw him on saturday
and uh he was really it was nothing much
left of him
of his body i would say he was really
just like a skeleton
but um he had a kind of very odd
and astounding peace to him and
and i really it really helped me
understand some aspects of symbolism in
a very
powerful way i would say in a way that's
it's not just
understanding it let's say in your
thoughts but
you know my cousin pascal he was really
an amazing person he was just an amazing
husband an amazing father he was just a
pillar in everything that he did
he was a straight shooter and uh just
you know that the kind of person who's a
motor in every group that he
is involved in he ends up being the kind
of fulcrum that
everything kind of turns around and
whatever he did was excellent
um and he was really involved in
people's lives in the sense that he
cared and he was there for people he was
there for me
all my life and um
and so what happened as he was kind of
passing away is
i all of a sudden i i saw all the seeds
that he had planted in other people
all the effort that he had put in all
the all the help he had given
you know all the times he had been there
for other people all of a sudden it just
started pouring back
on him and he was just flooded with love
and attention and people
you know praying for him and crying for
him
and uh it really made him glow i would
say in a way that i
i've never seen before and so i when i
went
i tried to go visit him about once a
week since he got sick maybe once a week
and a half or something
and uh as i saw him kind of
diminish his body i could see his glory
increase
and it was it's hard to explain it but i
really
it was really an experience of seeing
this dying man but also
seeing not with my eyes but seeing
this glory kind of coming out of him um
as all the fruits of his life were
coming to maturity
and so it was uh it was a good symbolism
symbolism happens moment um
despite the fact that i miss him very
much and so i'm gonna try to get through
these questions but i don't know how far
i'm gonna go
guys uh i'm gonna try and so
uh all right
so i just wanna say i really i really
appreciate
everybody you know all of this obvious
obviously
kind of makes you rethink everything and
and uh
try to be attentive to the people who
are around you
and and i just say i'm just so grateful
for the past few years
that all of you guys have given me a
chance to be able to to speak and to say
what i think and all your emails and i
know guys look i know
so many people have written me all kinds
of emails and i don't answer anymore but
you know it's not a reason to stop i'm
really touched by your emails i'm
touched by your story
i really appreciate you know when people
reach out to me
and uh and uh and i and i apologize that
i'm not able to
answer all the emails so all right here
we go
okay so carlos ponce vargas asked what
is the relationship between
mythos and ethos i would like to
understand how history is affected by
mythos
and how mythos are affected by history
so i'm not sure i totally understand not
try totally understand the relationship
between those two questions
i guess it just it depends how you what
you mean by
ethos you know if you mean ethos in the
sense of
morality the way that we kind of
understand it today then maybe
it's not enough but if you mean ethos
kind of in the ancient
manner in the sense of a manner of being
you would say
you know of a character something like
that something like
the the a way of being in the world
right the proper way of being in the
world a good way of being in the world
then i would say that there's definitely
a relationship between ethos and mythos
in the sense that ethos would be the
the being the way of being and then
mythos would be
the story would be you know the the way
that
that the way that ethos kind of
runs through time or runs through
different aspects of life
would look like mythos um
and so i would say i'd like to
understand how history is affected by
mythos and i'll meet those effects
history
if you mean by mythos you mean the
patterns if that's what you mean i hope
that's what you mean at least that's
what i mean when i use the word
if uh if that's what you mean then i
would say that
on the one hand mesos will affect
history
in the sense that it will be the pattern
of
historical movements and how history
affects mythos
it affects it in the sense that it
manifests the pattern in the particular
and so and so for example
different different um countries or
different peoples will
embody different aspects of the great
story or the great narrative
will embody more certain aspects and
then certain times in
history will also embody more fully
certain aspects of the story
right and so if depending on if if
if a civilization is ascending or
descending and it's
it's in its pursuits then it'll
obviously be embodying different aspects
of mythos
and that will affect the stories they
tell they'll end up telling
the aspect of stories which are closer
to that which they're embodying in
history
and so you know i keep saying things
like you know we are at the end of the
world
the edge of the world the end of the
world at the end of something you know
the end of a
of some cycle of some kind and so
because of that
then the types of mythological
representations we're seeing
are those that are related to the fringe
that are related to the exception that
are related
to all the things on the margin which is
why i talk about it so much because
i figure because it's what we're faced
with all the time
it's best we understand it so that we
can then understand the bigger pattern
which
obviously points us towards the center
hopefully at some point
um okay so david flores
asks is submitting embodying a principle
similar to hosting angels yes
i mean at least that's what my brother
met here talks about in his book
the language of creation that hosting
angels
is providing food for
a spiritual presence and so providing
body
and that's what embodying a principle is
and so
to properly host uh an angel is to
provide the right body
for the angel so that there's a fit when
there is a misfit
between the body and the principle
that's when you get monsters and when
you get
um disorderly things
it's most you know when i say it's like
it's the idea of understanding that
there's nothing that is bad
in itself things that are bad only when
they're not in their proper place and so
you know that there's nothing there's
nothing wrong with going to the bathroom
there's nothing wrong with that but
there's something wrong with going to
the bathroom in the kitchen
right that's that's where there's a
that's where monsters appear when
there's a misfit between
between the categories right anyways
okay
um
so adam chillard asked paul v
brought up the centurion from matthew 27
54
and it seems to me like you may have
wanted to say something
about it paul v sorry paul the fifth
paul vander clark like paul v who's that
uh any interesting
any interest in talking about this verse
matthew 27
54 when the centurion and those with him
who were guarding jesus saw the
earthquake and all that had happened
they were terrified and exclaimed surely
he was the son of god
i mean i think that that's an important
that's an important part of the story of
christianity
the way that the story is told in the
sense that
you know when christ talks about that
when a seed dies then the fruits
seed has to die for the fruit to appear
and so
in this case as they they saw they saw
the effects of the death of christ
then the foreigner the the romans
recognized the messiah and so that
moment
is then repeated let's say in the story
of the church
when the martyrs of the church uh
are dying constantly and at some point
the testimony of the martyrs and the
testimony of this
this for them foreign uh religion that
is that is kind of this kind of
pathetic thing all of a sudden it's that
testimony which ends up
converting the romans and so you can see
it play out
uh in the story of christ and you can
see it play out in the story of
christianity
um all right
by the way i just want to say that i
wouldn't i do i was scrolling through
fast and there are a lot of questions
like way too many questions there's no
way i'm going to get through all of
these
but i will try i will try um
all right okay and so
so dumash asked what are some
comparisons and contrast between
rabbinical midrash and the
theoria allegory of the church fathers
utilize in interpreting
scripture i would say that there is a
difference between midrash and
allegory or the way that the church
fathers will
interpret scripture in the different
levels of scripture
i would say that midrash is closer to
extra biblical
traditions and so for example i'll give
you
an example of christian midrash is
if you look in the icons of or if you
look at the feasts if you look at the
icons
there are some details which are
mentioned that are not in scripture
that means that it's like filling the
holes between
in the story and so that's what midrash
does it's like it fills in the holes
that are there and obviously a story
doesn't encompass everything
there are places where the attention
isn't turned and so midrash tends to
turn your attention
to a missing link in a story
in order to help you see more clearly
what the original story is about and so
there are versions of that in
christianity a good example that i
mentioned is that in scripture it
doesn't say that christ
was born in a cave it just says that he
was laid down in a manger
now to say that christ was born in a
cave
is something like midrash in the sense
that it's
an extra biblical tradition which helps
you understand the meaning of what is in
scripture which is
what is the meaning of being born in a
manger
is to be there in the lowest part in
the deepest part so the fact that he was
born in a cave in a manger
re-emphasizes that symbolism and there
are many examples of that as well
and so that is mostly where you will see
something akin to midrash
in christianity
all right and so
and i would say like i know a lot of
people won't be happy with what i'm
saying but i think it's useful
to look at midrash if you do so
in in a proper hierarchy that is if you
understand that
this is not let's say your text but you
look at midrash sometimes
the midrash can surprise you because
they will
they will will connect certain aspects
of the story
through some extra biblical tradition
extra biblical extrapolation
and it'll help you understand the story
as well um so it can be interesting it
just has to be in the
just has to be in the right place just
don't don't
you know don't put it in the hands in
the of the church for example that would
not work
um but you can see like if you read
saying if you read uh
senator from the syrian there is a lot
of stuff in his hymns on paradise which
could be considered
something like midrash in the sense that
it is
um in the sense that you know in
scripture
there are certain things that aren't
said about the garden but when saint
ephraim
says them says those things then all of
a sudden you can understand the story in
the garden better
you know the idea that uh for example
that there were no animals in the
paradise for example since
ephraim says that it's like okay so it
doesn't say that in scripture it doesn't
say the opposite it just doesn't say
that
so what it what could it mean that there
that adam had to come down the hill
of the mountain of paradise to name the
animals
you know what could that mean you can
see that there's a hierarchy
established and it's related and you can
see that then it's connected
to the animals that weren't allowed to
touch the the holy mountain of uh
with that moses went up to get the law
and you then all of a sudden you see
connections with other texts in
scripture which actually do
say that the animals can't go on the
mountain but the fact that
nephron will then say that in the story
of genesis that animals didn't touch the
mountain
right didn't go into the garden then you
can understand what that means all right
hope i'm not going too much on these
questions
all right okay
all right so egalis asks how can i best
raise my children
with a symbolic worldview i was raised
with a very literal view of scripture
and everything else and while i hope to
avoid that for them i feel like i'm
fumbling
and just confusing things i would say
the
worst thing to do with your kids is to
explain the symbolism like i do that
would be the
that'll be the very worst thing the way
that i explain symbolism is
for all of us who are lost it's for all
of us who
have lost symbolic thinking and so we
have to explain it normal
societies don't have to explain their
symbolism they just live them
and so the best way to help people have
children have a symbolic worldview
is to just point out analogies is to
just say
let's say you're reading um a story in
scripture
and then you can say oh doesn't that
remind you of another story
and ask them what it reminds them of
what other story reminds them of
then they might remember another story
in scripture or they might remember a
story from a fairy tale
or another story and so the idea is to
have a lot of stories
and to help your children see the
the the analogies between the stories
then when they get older
they can they'll just start to intuit
the patterns like i'm at that point for
example with my
oldest son who's 15 who really
has a good intuition and is able to see
the pattern sometimes
he surprises me and he says he watches a
movie and he says dad did you notice
that and i'm like oh i didn't
nice nice uh nice perception there
all right so cooper hayes asks
seeing as it has become particularly
political what is the symbolic
worldview of firearms certainly
something to do with a
technological extension man yes perhaps
a step away from our
experience of death um yes i mean
firearms are no different than other
weapons they
in the sense of their basic symbolism
they're related to weapons they're
related to swords they're related to
lances
um arrows all of those
they're of course they're more related
to something like an
arrow in the sense of it's not just
about
hitting but it's about also hitting a
point right so it's about
aiming and and hitting a
being true in your aim right and so it
has a very particular
it has a very particular aspect of
symbolism which has more to do with
with let's say shooting an arrow from
afar and hitting something
um and so it does have to do with
technology
and the extension and this notion
in uh genesis about the uh
the garments of skin which are then
extended into the cities and into
uh metallurgy etc etc
all right
all right so cooper hayes asks no sorry
he already asked that i already answered
so josh the mover asks
um many hygrography describe miracles
the likes of which we seem to see very
little of today
has the scourge of modernity and many
living outside of christian story caused
god to distance himself from us
such as these miracles no longer occur
with the same frequency or has the
complexity of the modern world simply
cause
these stories to be fewer and farther in
between
i think that there's for sure there
i would say that we are in dark times
that is probably part of it but there's
also
there's also a question of attention
um there are a lot of miracles that
still happened
today oh and then you say that later you
said upon doing my
some research you said i'm finding that
miracles happen far more often than i
was previously aware glory to god
yes i mean there are miracles that still
happen today and there are crazy things
that still happen today
um and so
i think that it's very difficult for us
to read those stories because it doesn't
see
they don't seem we don't seem to live in
that world and i think
one of the reasons why we don't see
miracles
is also part of our own like you said
it's part of our own
blandness and our own incapacity to
see and to participate in the magic of
the world
and so that is also one of the reasons
why i think that there are
that we see less miracles but there are
still miracles
um
so luca azovik asks he says oh my
goodness what does he say here he says i
know that
this is a semi-death sentence to ask a
modern orthodox christian
all right so let's see if i dare answer
this but since you opened the pandora's
box my questions are about
magic do you recommend any literature to
better understanding symbolically or
otherwise
what should i be careful of if i ever
come across someone who dabbles in it
what's the distinction between white and
black magic my goodness i primarily ask
these questions because i spent
a good part of my life trying to be as
objective as possible and it is
really difficult for me to see through
the symbolic lens and understand the old
way of seeing
this phenomena as opposed to the modern
one this modern will do as i
i also include the video game notion of
magic images are displays that some sort
of batteries
that when full expel yes exactly forget
about
the uh forget about the uh
kind of video game version of magic
the notion of magic is the idea that
you can use meaning to
create phenomena and that's why you'll
see a lot of people who
will say and and i and i think it's true
that there's
very little difference between magic and
technology
uh in the sense that it's a manner in
which you
you are able to take
uh an idea an image and you're able to
make it
appear in the world um
and so
one of the problems with magic
or the way that we understand magic is
we always understand it
as let's say some kind of
some kind we always want to understand
mechanically you know
and we don't really understand what
magic
can be if we try to understand the
meaning of it or
let's say powers or magic or something
like that you know
and so
let's say okay so i i'd like to give a
very silly example a very simple one
which kind of helped you understand why
magic
is is not the notion behind magic
isn't such a such a big deal
is that like do you believe in action at
a distance right you believe that you
can
say something and it'll happen
and the answer is obviously everybody
believes in that if you're silly
you'd have to be a total [ __ ] not to
believe in in action at a distance
you know if i have power and i have
authority then i can speak
something into being and it'll happen
even me as a father i can tell my son
hey elizae could you get a cup for me
and he'll go get the cup and he'll bring
it to me
voila action at a distance magic it's
magic that's what magic is
and so obviously i'm trying to i'm
trying to
i don't want to to to make it better now
i'm not saying that there are more
aren't more subtle
manners in which meaning can create
effects but that's the power
that you have to say something and it
happens
is that's the power behind magic and so
the problem with
let's say dark magic or evil magic or
that kind of stuff is there there are
other two things
one is the desire to use your power your
authority as a spiritual being
to affect the world in a way that
makes you more powerful and so in that
sense the sorcerer who is trying to
acquire power to himself
is very similar to someone who would do
that in the world through political
scheming and duo
and and through lying and convincing and
doing all that kind of stuff
and so that obviously is bad the other
problem is
invoking uh let's say invoking demons or
making yourself aligning yourself
with let's say
principalities that aren't in the
hierarchy or that aren't properly
aligned
in order to gain in order to gain power
for yourself
um and so that and that is
very dangerous it's dangerous for you
and it's dangerous from
for all for all the people around
and so i mean
yeah that's as much as i'm gonna say
now i would say that as a christian if
you're a christian i would say
it's better to just avoid that stuff
because that's not what we're called to
do we're not called
to use our meaning
use our words use our spiritual
capacities
to gain power and to accumulate
phenomena for our own sake like that's
not what we're called to do and so
in that sense it is not something that
we should be
but but i'm also being very trying to
keep it at the very rational but there
are more subtle ways in which this stuff
works
i used a very simple example which is to
say you know
i asked someone to do something and they
do it but there are
more subtle ways and yes there are
uses of different patterns and different
rituals which can
which can manifest the patterns in the
world
of course there are but it's probably
best to stay away from that stuff
because that's not what that's not our
point that's not a purpose in the world
all right okay hopefully i haven't
confused
everybody with that answer so keenan
cronin asked i really struggled to
control my passions
you've talked about this before but what
advice would you give when it comes to
learning to control your passions
it's prayer enough it's simply about
discipline what can i do to become a
better mediator between
heaven and earth um
i mean
i mean prayer for sure prayer for sure
knowing yourself and knowing where your
weaknesses are
and seeing them from afar i think i've
talked about this before
knowing not the step where you give in
but
the steps before the steps you give in i
mean i think that that's helpful
in uh in in kind of helping you
control your passions it's probably good
to have someone to talk to
to have of course i would say a
confessor is the best but
to have someone that you can talk to
about
what you're struggling and that person
can give you advice
and also you know in a way the best
would be that someone can actually get
an authority
over you so that so that you kind of
give up your will
to to someone else and that's helpful
too because
that's the giving up your
your will to someone else or to
something above you is the very
mechanism by which you
you are healed from your passions
because your passions are giving in to
your particular wills in a disorderly
manner
hmm
all right so alex riddle asks
how does the symbolism of the mass
compare contrast to the veil
one obvious parallel particularly
resonant with the mask that we're
currently wearing is that they're both
meant to protect what is behind
the veil mass from the outside while at
the same time protecting the outside
from what is veiled mass
however as you recently noted on twitter
a key piece of
mass symbolism is the breakdown of
identity in order to make a new one
clearly that runs counter to the
ostensible purpose of protection
so is the mass merely an inversion of
the veil or just this negative aspect or
something like that
like the veil that simulates in order to
preserve while the mass assimilates in
order to dissolve
in which case the kind of mass we're
wearing right now might be said might
said to serve both as mass and as veils
i don't know what do you think
it's a complicated question a lot of
people have asked me to do a video on
masks
i was thinking about doing one um but
it's difficult because it's so touchy
for people and it's
because it's so right now it's very
difficult
to talk about that without emotions kind
of flaring up but
i would say in terms of the pattern the
reason why we're asked to wear masks
right now is extremely similar
analogically
to to the veils to the veils
in the temple to the veil that moses
wore
but like all symbolism
it doesn't necessarily it's it doesn't
not necessarily positive and it's not
necessarily negative it can be both
the i the purpose of wearing a mask is
is especially a mask that doesn't have
features
is to separate you right it's to
it's to separate you from others and so
you can want to separate people from
others for good reasons
and you can want to separate people from
others with bad reasons
you know you can separate people from
others in order
to dissolve their bonds of communion
right especially if you're doing it like
everybody's where everybody's separated
from each other
now
it can also be a way to create a new
form of communion
right because as you dissolve the bonds
that we normally have
then the mask can become like a blank
slate on which to
write a new a new identity right that
we'll all
share so that's also part of it but i
i'm hoping i can make a video on this
but i would say that ultimately it's the
same reason in terms of pattern
but like i said it's not always good
so gary new nuila says what's the
significance of the fact that god
is the one who introduces the first
supplement and technology in the
garments of skin
while the other supplement tech
technologies are introduced by the
descendants of cain
so what you have to understand in
the fact that god introduces the
garments of skin
is you have to understand it as a kind
of condescension
you have to understand it as a
as a giving in right to the situation
where as man falls
god puts on the protection and so
it's it's not it's a
it's a good thing god gives the garments
of skin to adam and eve out of
compassion and i would say that
to a certain extent each layer
of the garments of the supplement
are both a positive and a negative all
the time
they're both negative in the sense that
they are a mark of moving away from the
center
but they are both positive in the sense
that they are a protection
so that you don't fall further and so
it's a it's a double bind all the time
that's the that's the duality of the
supplement that i always talk about
right it's a poison
it's a cure you know it's a it's an
extent it's an extension of yourself so
it's more death but it's death
protecting you from death
and so but it's already there in in what
god did
it's just that it's a process which will
as it follows its own course will lead
to death
right you know the the wages of sin are
death
but god gives us the garments of skin to
halt or to slow down the process
of death to give us a chance
while we're in this body of death
all right so bleeding mermaid asks
what is the proper christian we are
thinking of what happens to us when we
die
i had a disturbing dream recently of
losing a loved one the only thing that
could console me was
the thought that by memory unity through
long distance i was brought back in
unity with them
and of course christ conquered death so
by being in the body of christ we're not
destroyed by death
but i would like more detail on this by
observing how some protestants talk
about
how somebody dies is in a better place
it sounds like the dead are detached
from this world but i believe we still
have a body or some sort of extension in
the world
even after we die is that correct
um
so in the orthodox church we say
we say that we ask for memory eternal
for eternal
memory and that is really
you hit on the nail in the right place
that
memory is the manner in which
we exist after death that is god
remembers us and we also remember
each other in prayer and the saints
remember
us and so it is through communion it's
through the communion
of all of us that
we have god that we exist
you know in a different manner
after our bodies are are are broken
and so
so the idea that the dead are totally
detached from the world i think is
is just not possible and i and i
understand why people say that
but and it's kind of like an arbitrary
thing that people say
but they they are still connected to us
because we remember them
and in a mysterious way they remember us
and so they are still
you know they they are still in a very
mysterious way
we are still connected to them
um and yes they still have
in a certain manner a body you could say
but it's a body in the eschaton it's a
it's a body that which will be revealed
when all is revealed right
the body of all things will come to
fruition when everything
is revealed so it's difficult to
understand this stuff so we talk about
it and
we talk about it very much in signs and
symbols in science
and then here it's really is that
you know a kind of language that we talk
about something beyond
our immediate understanding we use words
to talk about them
um so yeah
all right
all right so
let's continue i think i think i have
all the
i think i have all the comments from the
website
so let's go on to patreon
all right i hope everybody in the chat
is doing okay
as i said there are so many questions
it's very difficult and i don't know how
people do it i don't know how people
are able to follow the chat at the same
time
as they're doing the q and a's i just
can't so i apologize for that guys
but uh it's very difficult for me to
follow the chats
especially if i don't want i don't want
this to be like three hours long i don't
know how people do that
all right so similar question here
nikola asks what would be the most
succinct way of talking
about life after the last judgment to
someone who is not religious
or maybe even for the religious types as
well
so a good way to understand
it's very difficult to understand the
idea of eschaton but it's not
that difficult in the sense that
obviously
people if someone hasn't broken their
kind of materialist
science you know kind of bad science
scientistic thinking um
then they won't be able to understand
but
so a good way to understand is that
the okay so the logos
the logos the the reason right
the principle the
the let's say the reason for something
right the origin and the reason for
something
as the thing is going so imagine
i make uh i make uh
i'm making a spoon right and i'm i'm
working on it and i'm working on it
and so while i'm working on the spoon
okay
the logos of the spoon
is is it's it's telos it's that which
i'm working towards
and it's it's drawing it to it
right the logos of the spoon is drawing
the spoon
to itself so i'm making the spoon to
make it resemble
this the spoon-ness of the spoon so that
it can function as a spoon and so
as as i am working on it
the logos is let's say it's merciful
the logos is merciful because
it's kind of it's calling upon me to
continue and make the spoon
and i have still room to make the spoon
more like a spoon
as i'm working on it but once i'm
finished
right once the spoon is finished then
the logos of the spoon becomes its judge
it judges the spoon because it's done
and now the the the logos of the spoon
will judge whether or not
it was a good spoon and where
it where it is in the hierarchy of
of spoons okay i didn't use cup this
time
and so now take that notion right and so
the idea is that some of the spoons
are going to be like recognized
as being proper spoons good and faithful
servants
and some of the spoons are not
good spoons and they they they don't
work as spoons
and so then those get tossed into the
fire as
christ talks about when he talked about
this stuff
and so the logos who is calling all
these spoons to himself
when they're finished then they then
they're judged and some are cast aside
and some are kept
and so that is so it take that process
and now imagine it
for all of everything
imagine uh spread that knowledge
like take that notion and like pull it
all the way out
and then that that's when you can
understand what it means for the what
the last judgment means
and what it means that some things will
not have reached their
proper purposes and then will fall away
and some things
even like within yourself and we always
want to see it as
people getting cast into hell or you
know people getting cast into heaven but
you can also understand it as the
aspects of you
which will also be cast away and
and and that of you which is closer to
christ will
be brought into christ like you can see
it that way as well and but
that's also a form of judgment where
it's happening at every level of reality
at the same time
and so that's what the last judgment is
and the last judgment is not
an event in history i'm sorry to say
it is the end right it is that which
happens when all has happened
that would ha that which happens when
all has been revealed and so it's not
it's not a it's not a normal event
right
all right that's as good as i'm gonna
get guys you got me on
on a bad date and you always you you're
already talking about death what's up
with that
it's not a good day to talk about death
okay here's a better one all right
dorothy kk says hi jonathan can you
comment on the symbolism of shoes
like in losing your shoes unfitting or
wrong shoes glass shoes like in the
cylinder store etc
so so shoes are really coverings they're
they're
they're a great example of covering
their
garments of skin in the sense that they
are
that which protect your feet from the
outside world but
there also can also be a type of glory
and you can see that because you know
some people
who have a lot of shoes and and
definitely see shoes
as their glory and so you and so
understanding
the notion of losing your shoes means
losing
your covering like losing the means you
have
to engage with the world and so you lose
so uh
a shoe that doesn't fit you know means
that
it's this lack of fitting between the
manifestation of something
and it's like the the miss
the the wrong hosting of angels you
could say that
hosting angels is also putting on the
proper shoes
for the angel's feet to touch the ground
right you could see it that way
that could be a good way to understand
the symbolism of shoes it's like
providing the proper shoes so that the
angel can touch the ground
because the angel needs shoes or else
his bare feet cannot touch
um so that's a good way to understand it
and so in the glass shoe in cinderella
it's interesting because i
talk about this in one of my videos it
might be a patron only video i'm not
sure is it i don't remember anyways
i talk about cinderella and the glass
shoe
and i talk about how the the
in french there's this confusion because
the shoe is made
of and there's this there's a legend
that the word
actually refers to type of fur and then
some people say no it doesn't it's wrong
but it doesn't matter
there's a story which says that there's
a mistake that it's not glass dipper
slippers but it's fur slippers
and that's really this this relationship
between death and glory that i talk
about all the time
the relationship between the crown and
the horns of the animal
all of that type of symbolism that i i
talk about
all right and so we're done with the
website and we're going on to
patreon and on patreon there's like
25 questions
all right we can do this
so i wish i could hear you guys but
maybe not all at the same time
like if i could hear a few people
kind of encourage me to keep going
all right i think i've got them all out
here
all right okay here we go
all right so blake payne asks i've been
reading a lot of
mircia eliade and just finished the myth
of eternal return
he seems to take issue with the concept
of history that the judeo-christian
worldview introduces as its opposition
to a more cyclical view
the idea that god acts in time and then
marks that time and creates a linear
view of reality
where there is a beginning and an end
what are your thoughts on this and how
do we look at it symbolically
well blake the way we look at it
symbolically is that it's just all
hogwash it is absolute hogwash that
christianity presents a linear view of
history
you know there's so many scholars say
that and you just want to slap them
around because
what are you talking about seriously
what are you talking about
my goodness it is clear when you read
and it's so clear in scripture
that when you read in scripture all that
christ is doing
is a kind of recap and return and
transformation of
the story in genesis when you look at
how the story ends in
in revelation that it's a return into
the garden
and an adding of the crown of the city
around the garden and so it's not a
linear view of history
by no means it is a it is a kind of
giant giant cycle where the end
of the cycle comes into the beginning
but transforms the beginning
by giving it an end and so it's actually
shows us the fullness of the cycle so
it's not that it's just
one story with the beginning and an end
it's that it's what the christian story
is showing
is the the giant giant giant cycle
the ultimate eternal ultimate cycle
you know the pattern of which all the
small cycles
are are patterned on and so
and so it's just not just not linear i
don't know what to say
and i i really really am annoyed because
i don't see
i just don't see you read read like
when when it's when the church fathers
or when it when christ says
to the the the to the the good thief he
says
tomorrow you will be with me in paradise
he's saying he will be with me in the
garden
how can that be linear he's bringing
them back he's bringing
the the the thief back into the garden
he's bringing the end into the beginning
and so
i don't know i just i like
merci eliade and and but i mean i think
he just gets wrong i'm just
there's just so many people who get it
wrong so many people and it really is a
weird
i think it's like an enlightenment view
of of
of christianity which wants to see
christianity in its own idea of progress
and all this kind of nonsense
um all right sorry i'm gonna start to
rant now it's not good
it's not good okay
all right and the milligan another
question if i may
i started uh so another question i'll
just answering one question sorry andy i
just
i just can answer one question each
because it's just too much okay so andy
milligan asked i watched a video of your
talk
and q a from saint john kansas church he
talked about hierarchy
in state flag the church the market et
cetera
the model of this brought to mind was of
a chess board
so what is the symbolism of chess what
can we learn as society
starts to chip away at the levels
monarchy american revolution the church
et cetera well there are a lot of
questions in your
in your question my friend um
okay um
so what's this maybe i could just answer
your question what's the syllabus of
chess
the symbolism chest is very powerful
it's a very very powerful uh
symbolism because it really does have to
do with
the interaction of two opposites it
really is a war
um and it can
make you understand the relationship
between opposites
even on the board because it has black
and white and you know you're not
allowed to
to to you have to follow a certain rules
of movement
on the board um and so there
it really is a it also chess really is
powerful because
it forces you it really is pattern
thinking is it forces you to
think of
straight let's say straight movement
diagonal movement
and crooked movement and a kind of crook
movement okay
and so you have certain figures that
move
in in an s shape and then you have
you have uh the the
certain figures that move straight and
then you have those that move diagonal
then you also have
of course uh one that moves in every
single way and so it's like that
is really very powerful in terms of
understanding possibility
within the world like how to deal with
how to
how do you answer someone who's moving
crooked how do you answer how do you
deal with someone who's
moving straight how do you deal with
someone who's coming at an angle for you
so it's a very very powerful microcosm
we'd probably take like a full video to
talk about the symbolism of chess
maybe another video i if i counted the
number of times that i said i should
make a video about that
it probably would be very embarrassing
all right okay so ronnelle canada i'm
sure
is that that can't be your real name
ronnelle all right so hey hey jonathan i
just finished reading the life of moses
by saint gregory and as i find myself
progressing from the standpoint of
constantly looking to christ in order to
avoid the pull away
from the passions i find it harder to
experience rely on the salvific passion
that saint gregory
references in his book i think my
confusion is that i don't really
know the qualities associated with this
new way of being
could you describe the qualities of this
new passion and how we might cultivate
it today
thanks so much um and so i mean
the idea is that our passions are
made are not bad our passions are
fine our passions are actually
the way in which we are deified right
we're deified
passion just means the capacity to move
towards something else
right that's what passion is passion is
the capacity to move
uh the capacity to move towards a
an object that that attracts you and so
that's also with what god does and so
the idea is that each person each
passion
has its opposite in a virtue
and that those virtues are
they're you could say they're
dispassionate in a way
but they're also you could say in terms
of god
they are also passionate in the sense
that god is
pulling us towards him um but it's true
the idea is that
that's that's the paradox about
christianity is that
is that as you tame your passions like
the passions that
are have power over you then it opens up
the possibility for those passions to
kind of push you up or to pull you up
into
into uh into love but you know i'm not a
saint so
it's very it's very uh theoretical
i mean it's not theoretical completely
but it is theoretical to a certain
extent because if i
it wasn't i would i would be a holy
person and probably wouldn't be on
youtube
all right okay so joshua martin says hi
jonathan some of the folks on the
discord server have a wager going on an
art question for you
what do you think of william blake
[Music]
all right so what do i think of william
blake well okay so i think that
this is the thing this and this question
is it
refers can refer to all the kind of
let's a
[Music]
romantic artist or artists who were
flirting with
occult ideas in in the enlightenment and
in post-enlightenment
and so and i think william blake is one
of those and i think that
blake and i've said this before i think
that blake's
and other people of that time i think
that
their disillusioned with the humdrum
christianity that they were facing
was what was kind of pushing them
to search for more mystical answers and
so
in that search i think sometimes
they get it right and i think a lot of
times they also get it wrong and so
sometimes i'll look at an image
uh a drawing by blake for example and
i'll find it
very inspiring and uh even in the way
that he uses a kind of iconic
digital language and uh there's very
powerful imagery
and then other times i look at us at an
image from william blake and i'm like
sorry dude you just you just fell off
right there you just
you're missing something like you don't
get it um and so
i think i think that's the same for a
lot of
a lot of the thinkers of that period
all right so charlie longoria says hello
jonathan i had a question about jordan
peterson's interpretation of the word
meek
which is something like those who have
swords and know
how to use them but keep them sheathed
is this right i'm not sure
where he's getting his translation yeah
i don't know where he's getting his
translation either
i can kind of understand the thrust of
his answer which is that
there's nowhere in in christianity
that it is suggested that weakness
you know is
there's only one place and it's in st
paul where he talks about
boasting of his weaknesses but i would
say that
the idea is to be one of the aspects of
the being unique
is the idea of being dispassionate in
the way that we talked about
it's the idea of not letting other
things
uh rule you and rule you by provoking
you to action
right and so when someone someone
insults you and you retort which i've
done number of times
i'm not uh free from that sin
uh then you are actually making yourself
a slave to them right
you are actually and so meekness
is the capacity to not be taken
by passion but it doesn't mean that you
ca that you so in the sense that
in the sense that you are it's a form of
strength it's not a form of
of weakness it's the capacity to not be
affected and to not be
kind of you know that's the way i see it
i might be wrong
today is a bad it's a bad day for
all right okay i'm losing control here
let's let's keep it together
okay so hi jonathan could you tell us
what you think of the
mindfulness revolution this is paul
jamal
of the mindfulness revolution and the
current trend from psychologists like
john
viveki to use to use oriental
spirituality
as psychology students i see a lot of it
and it makes me somewhat uneasy
but i cannot put my finger on what
bothers me about it exactly
seems to have something to do with
father stephen freeman's warning about
the modern tendency
to see spiritual practices as mere
techniques
yes i agree i totally agree i think that
i think that there's something about the
mindfulness
revolution which is extremely
individualistic and
continues in the kind of individualism
of the modern world
and uh which is why it wants to create
technique without story
technique without cohesion you know
techniques without love
that kind of thing and so now
so it doesn't mean that mindfulness is
is bad there's of course mindfulness is
is fine
in the church we are said to always
remember
remember death that's the way christians
talk about mindfulness
is to remember your death and
that so so it is to be attentive
to your sins to be attentive to the
places where you misstep
to the places where to see yourself in
your
in your uh
in your crookedness you could say and so
to be mindful of your sins and to be
mindful of god to remember god
to remember your sins those two things
at the same time to always remember
that there's something above you and to
always
be aware of the places where you are
stepping aside
and so that is the way that mindfulness
is a form of mindfulness
is has always been part of christianity
so wait a good way to understand that if
you want to connect it to something like
uh
the mindfulness revolution it's there is
something about that so for example like
if you were to be mindful of your death
while you pray what you would be doing
is as you're praying let's say you're
praying to jesus prayer
and you're you're repeating the jesus
prayer and all of a sudden
you notice that you're saying jesus
prayer
but then you're also thinking about
something else right so that's
that's a form of remembering death like
noticing the places where you die
noticing the places where
you break apart where your being is
broken and fragments
and so when you notice that often it can
be enough to snap things back together
to snap
the fragments back into the hole um and
so that's a good way to use it as a
christian
uh so aj daltorio asked hey jonathan i
hope you vince well
the other day my friend asked me why
there are so many terrible christian
movies and books
i remember you mentioning how modern
stuff doesn't even compare to writers
like dostoyevsky so i was wondering if
you had any thoughts on what went wrong
thanks yes i can i can i think i've said
it before it's that
christians don't understand the
christian story
the most of the bad christian uh movies
and books
come from a world where they have this
idea
that the bible and christianity is about
being saved and the purpose of our
existence in the world
is to be a testimony to others so they
can also
be saved and that they can go to heaven
and so if you live in a world like that
i mean what
exactly how can you make anything
besides propaganda
like how could you because that's what
you think your entire
existence is about you think that you're
here in the world
to evangelize and so what is that gonna
be
so i don't know it's just and so i think
that if christians understood
the the power and the amazing
narrative that is in scripture if they
could embody it
if they could be inside it
then all of a sudden the the stories
they would tell would be better because
they would be telling stories that have
analogies to the stories in scripture
they would be
they would be embodying the pattern
instead of
instead of a weird kind of
propagandistic move to hide your message
enough
you know to either like have the message
out there so that people get converted
or because you feel bad about that you
try to hide the message but secretly
you'd really like people to understand
the message so that they can also be
saved
yeah all that it's just all it's really
not
not useful at all all right
all right so mark kalashnikov
i was hoping you could explain the
transfiguration in 30 seconds
just kidding hoping for a few thoughts
if it's not too much to ask maybe in
reference to the sleep of the disciples
peter not knowing comment in a cloud
that overshadowed them
in which they fearfully entered thank
you for your work
so i would say if you want to hear about
the transfiguration
um
do i talk about that
probably not um
30 seconds i mean the transfigure the
transfiguration is basically
just an image of the whole story it's
always the same story
going up the mountain going to the top
of the mountain and then
in that top of the mountain there's a
joining of light and darkness
glory of christ but also an
overshadowing
presence and so it's shadow and light at
the same time and
and those that are below the mountain
can't look at it because they have to
cover themselves
just like adam and eve had to cover
themselves in order to
to uh to to uh
not to to to be there and then saint
peter says
we will build tents and so we will we
will host
these spiritual presence we will host
these spiritual
uh appearance in the world um
and that's that's it
that's christianity is building a tent
or being a tent for christ
all right nick scott says hello mr pedro
can you talk about the symbolism of
wings
are they related to spirit breath since
they are always ways to move air
i'm thinking in particular beasts from
revelation whose wings made a terrifying
sound if i'm on track that would be the
symbolism
of wings covered with eyes this is a
topic already covered
so yeah the idea of wings is definitely
related to spirit it's that
it's related to that which is above that
which flies above
and if uh wings have eyes
then it's also connecting it to meaning
directly connecting it to meaning
so you have this notion of a spirit that
has
wings and that can see through its wings
and therefore that which is
keeping it above you is also that which
can see the world
and which can identify the world i like
the word identify because it's a word
that
talks about seeing but also giving
meaning to um
so yeah usually in general if you find a
story where something has a lot of eyes
it's usually has to do with that has to
do with
um a kind of
hyper consciousness or hyper awareness
so don palermo asks jonathan from
timothy
1 timothy 6 19.
instruct them to do good to be rich in
good works to be generous
and ready to share storing up for
themselves the treasures of a good
foundation
for the future so that they may take
hold
of that which is life indeed
storing up for themselves the treasure
of a good foundation for the future
so that they may take hold of that which
is life indeed
um so what do you think of the the
meaning of working for future heavenly
treasure
i mean what do you mean i don't what do
i mean would use it mean to work for a
future heavenly treasure
um
i mean it means
it means the same thing as any form of
planting that you do in order to get
fruit in the future
okay so so let's say you have a plant
and then you let's use a good example
let's use a simple example which is that
you have wheat
so you grow wheat and you get the wheat
now that wheat
you eat that wheat right you make bread
out of it but then
you take a part of it and you you
sacrifice it you don't eat it
you you put it in the ground um
and you do that because you
are storing up treasure for the future
right um and so that's the thing with
good works is that
some people are going to be annoyed with
me because i i'm really gonna i'm gonna
bring this
down to you guys in a very practical way
which is that
if you're nice to people you are putting
seeds
in them so that later on
there's a better chance that they'll be
nice to you
it doesn't necessarily work that way
there is a way in which
you can there is a kind of a an even
higher manner in which
the saint will plant seeds in others and
he will not bear fruit in this life and
therefore
this idea that the fruit that you don't
get in this life
are accumulated for you right but you
understand the process
because that's what we do all the time
right you you
if you don't love your kids good luck
when you get old right
if you love your kids and you care for
them then
then you will be planting seeds for
for fruit in the future um and so it's
the same pattern but
take it to its ex take it to its extreme
there's a matter in which
like i said if you do good and you do
not get
the reward it's as if you're storing up
in the world
bigger and bigger treasure
hi jonathan throughout roman catholic
tradition there have been instances of
eucharistic miracles where the host
bleeds
have there been any in in in eastern
church i don't know if there are any of
those miracles
uh at the top of my head i do not
remember any
wow we got a lot of questions left guys
i'm already running out of steam here
all right
[Music]
all right okay so arie fisher asked hi
jonathan i was wondering if you
would be willing to talk about the
significance of the paraphrase passage
from jacob and esau's reunion that your
brother opens his book with
i tried to puzzle puzzle over it myself
but i've only come up with some vague
intuitions and nothing super satisfying
as of yet
perhaps jacob's story fits the pattern
of how materialism stroll the birth out
of religion
all right i will type the patch let me
i'll give you guys a hint
i won't tell you what it's fully about
some of you probably already know
i will type the passage out below in
case you don't remember oh i remember it
here we go he said esau quote
i have enough brother let that which is
yours
be yours jacob please take my gift
because god has shown me grace
and i also have enough esau
let us take our journey together then
and i will go
before you jacob i will journey
according to the place of the flock and
children
until i come unto you my brother unto
sare
so if you want to understand that
question
that that passage you have to understand
that
jacob and esau never met
that is jacob told esau he says
esau says let us take our journey
together
and i will go before you and then jacob
says
basically i will come and meet you
but he never does
and so matsir is
calling for that to happen he's calling
for jacob
to meet and join
with esau
now you have to know who jacob is
it's a little harder to understand who
esau is
if you understand who jacob is at least
that'll be
that'll help you understand the rest all
right so
daniel demarco says hi jonathan can the
wheel of revolution
ever be turned backwards or once it is
past a certain point
must it bring an end to the old world
and usher in a new one
can a new world ever come about
peacefully or must it always be preceded
by pain and violence dude i'm afraid i
know the answer but maybe there are
instructive counter examples
well if there are instructive counter if
there are
counter examples i don't know any
death comes before life you know that
seems to happen
all the time all right so
leo asks hi jonathan christians
generally defined far eastern religion
that's gnostic anti-matter even
anti the body and yet yoga martial arts
etc are some of its fruits
compared to christianity
then emphasizes fasting and martyrdom
does this me seem like a contradiction
to you
i mean i don't think that farts to
religion are necessarily gnostic
antimatter so
it's like i don't know i think that
people say that
i mean there's a hierarchy
for sure like in hinduism there's
definitely a hierarchy between let's say
that which is spiritual and that which
is material there's a
there's a hierarchy but um they also
especially something like hinduism they
also believe that
the spiritual world has to find body in
the world right
that's why they have these different
practices and they have rituals and they
have all this stuff so so um so i don't
know
so i don't i've never thought that i've
never thought that
that they're necessarily gnostic or
anti-matter um
if they are then then then they're off
all right
jason lindsey asks hey jonathan an image
that seems to be appearing more and more
in modern stories is a being in
particular a higher being from the
heavens
that has no mouth but can still clearly
communicate with others
is there anything like this from
scripture myths or history
or is it a modern phenomena seems to
have its origin in this sci-fi genre and
has spread elsewhere
from fantasy to horror to even religious
works i've had no luck finding medieval
or ancient versions of these images
what would be the symbolic meaning of a
being that has no mouth that can
communicate
in others with other clearly as if it
were speaking
um yeah i don't think i've ever seen
versions
um i've never seen stories that where
that
happens i think it's pretty simple what
it means it
it's a there's the the symbolism of
telepathy or the symbolism of
communicating
through thought is the idea of
is that is the possibility of community
of clear communication
right of communicating without the
accidents of language
and so that's why you said it's a higher
being that will be that will do that
because it's it's as if something from
above
is infusing meaning directly into you
right
and so i think that that would be the
reason why they would use that kind of
symbolism you know it makes sense
is helping your needy neighbor an
instance of not accounting for
everything
like how the good samaritan lets himself
get interrupted
yeah i think that's a good that's a good
that's a very good
way of understanding because
you know it's interesting it's like in
the story of the good samaritan there's
so much in that story and just like
everything christ says
there's so much in everything he says
but in that story there's so much
because you you have this
sense that there's someone on a path
that's kind of
that has a purpose and then he is
distracted by death he's distracted by
not he's not completely dead but he's
he's
mostly dead let's say he
he gets distracted by death and and then
you can see what the difference so it's
like that's the story of genesis
that's what happens it's like we're
supposed to go up
and then and then adam and eve get
distracted by death and they end up
going down
and then they get they end up being
falling into
that distraction but in the story of the
good samaritan
it's like the answer to the problem it's
saying
christians answer the problem
of death by caring for those
who are falling for those who are down
on the ground for those who have lived
and so it's like that's the answer
that's the christian answer
the christian answer to suffering is to
help those who suffer
the christian answer to it to to death
is to bring the light of god into the
dark places
and so it really is the same story as
that that which we see in genesis it's
just showing you what the christian
answer is to that
all right so eb asked what is a good
place to start in exploring a deeper
spiritual life for christians who have
so far
stayed more at the surface level
[Music]
i mean it depends it depends how far
your your your
you want to go i mean
i would say read the church fathers you
know read especially certain church
fathers
i know i mentioned saint gregor nissa
uh senator from the syrian but there's
also
church itself you know i would say it's
hard now because of cogan and
everything's crazy and everything's so
insane but
you know the idea would be to look to to
attend a traditional church service and
see how it fits together in terms of
actual practice and
um yeah look at the old things
try to understand them
all right so ken and wang asks i was
wondering if you could talk about the
idea of obedience as it relates to the
tree
of knowing good and evil in particular i
noticed that passion seems to be a
desire to know things
that are chaotic or strange i've also
frequently felt that innocence lost and
regained
or faith lost and regained
so i guess maybe my question is what is
the place for rebellion
how does the story of the fall or of
christ inform obedience or rebellion
when we are faced with passions so
i mean you could kind of understand
like the best way to understand
rebellion
in the sense there isn't an absolute
rebellion you're always rebelling to one
thing in order to submit to another
like that's very important to understand
you know the idea of
rebelling towards absolute freedom is
just just that it's just
it's just a delusional uh impression of
reality and so
a way to use the trope of rebellion
is the notion of rebelling against the
world of death rebelling against
the passions rebelling against so there
is a possibility
to use that type of imagery
um but you always have to understand
that it's happening in a manner
which is that you are making yourself a
servant a slave
to god and to and to the actual
ruler of things so if you want to look
at some people who are doing that you
can see
you know uh there's a company called
death to the world they write some
some um they also have some magazines
that they put out i'm supposed to write
an article for them but it just seems to
not be happening for some reason
but um you can look up deaths of the
world and they're kind of using the
trope of rebellion
to kind of turn death against death and
to turn like
what do they say the last true rebellion
is the rebellion against this world and
then a submission to god
um
all right so herman smith asks
my question is about your comments in
recent videos that science is running up
against the problem of consciousness
i feel woefully out of the loop about
that
are there any particular videos you
would suggest to shed some light on this
um man which videos i think i talk about
that all the time
um
the okay so the problem of consciousness
is the problem of attention
it's the problem of the too much of the
world
the world is too much it has too many
things it's it's indefinite in number
right all things explode into millions
of detail
so the problem is why do we attend to
certain things because we have to
we can't account for all the facets of
all things it just
it's just there's just too many and so
that is when we
understand that attention and
consciousness
and this experience we have of the world
is central
for the world to cohere and for us to be
able to make sense of it
and ultimately for it to exist in the
manner in which we
experience it and so that's what i mean
by hitting against consciousness as for
videos i don't
remember at the top of my head which
videos
talk about that specifically
so in the language of creation your
brother writes the realization
quoted above genesis 8 21 implies that
evil is inherently part of humanity
which means a certain degree of wrong
must be acknowledged for its perfection
more precisely there exists a higher
reality a meta-space in which a certain
degree of lower evil can be transmuted
into a higher good
for the knowledge of god this is the
spiritual truth that adam and eve were
not equipped to handle in the garden of
eden
which led to their death is this another
way of putting the idea of transforming
death into glory
or about the inability on the part of
humanity to adequately acknowledge or
integrate the fringe
or time adequately into space i think so
i would say
the way that matsuri phrases it is
difficult in terms of christian theology
um but i think that and so so i probably
wouldn't phrase it that way and i think
someone asked in a question that i
didn't read because i answered it before
um like what's what are the differences
between matthew and i
and i've not mentioned this before in a
q a this would be the
the thing where i the way that he
phrases that particular text
is one which is difficult for christians
but
i think that if we understand it as
the notion that
there's a way there's a relationship
between
death and glory and that
it's that there's something about their
incapacity to
to to fully see that that
because they were unable they weren't
ready to see the glory of god
that glory fragment
fragmented for them and fragmented them
and broke them
brought them to see the the
or to embody the the multiplicity of
glory like the shining
but it's there's also this notion that
it's a can also be a kind of fragmenting
and that's what happened that's that's
the problem is that
is that the the multiplicity became a
fragmenting rather than being a kind of
shining kind of overflowing of of being
you could say
um so but it is it is difficult to say
that it's inherently part of humanity
right it's complicated because in the
text it says the knowledge of good and
bad so it means that
you could say something like the
possibility of
of absence or something i don't quite
know how to phrase it properly
i'm probably getting into deep water
just by talking about this stuff anyways
all right
all right guys i'm going to do a few
more and then i think i'm done because
i'm just running out of voice even
all right so dionysus asked hello
jonathan i would like to ask a question
on the pattern
of covering the nakedness of our father
i sometimes observe specific issues in
christian culture
especially in its more dogmatic levels
as things seem
to me much clearer and coherent in the
mystical level i find myself
desiring to criticize and expose these
issues as hiding them seems insincere
and also detrimental
in the long run covering seems to
suggest a respectful adding of a lair
instead of a shaming criticizing but is
nevertheless
does not signify ignorant or denying
could you elaborate
on the manner of this covering
is there a story where it is presented
in more detail thanks
um i mean i think the story of noah is
really the best story to understand this
covering
i'd have to think about it to see if
there are other stories which are
which are similar but
i'm not saying there isn't a way to do
that like let me give you an example of
someone who doesn't do that
there there's st john the baptist
doesn't do that
right saint john the baptist calls out
the king right
says he is scandalous and calls out the
authorities
says that they're scandalous so and
christ does it as well christ uncovers
the pharisees
he says that they are believed sepulcher
self-occurs he says that they are
hypocrites says that their inside and
their outside doesn't match
so
there is a there is a time to do that
but
i live by the sword die by the sword you
know christ said that
and that's what happened so
there's that as well so i don't know i
don't know it's like the
the there's also
the notion that the you know the the
measure by which you judge
that is the measure by which you will be
judged and so you have to be careful
when you uncover the scandals of others
because everybody has scandals everybody
has
something they would want the world to
see so
so yeah but i don't know where the line
is i look i
i all i know is the ones that i see in
my own reality and my own
and it's not my responsibility to call
out
you know other people it's not those
those that are not my father it's not my
responsibility to call out their
nakedness anyways
and so i have to i have to be attentive
to what's happening around me and if i
see that there are some things which are
bubbling over and are too scandalous
then we have to
see how to do it in a way that is proper
it's as good as it's gonna get
so sean carnowin asks it seems like most
people on the right
have half of the political spectrum
have correctly identified woke speech
and identity policing as a serious
threat
to the existing liberal order
however i am of the opinion that most on
the right are pretty blind to the
ongoing material
physical experience of police brutality
and corruption that sparked the current
fire
in the same mode police people on the
left are blind to the injustice of the
woke social
policing which is brutal in its one own
way
it's as though each polarity has a piece
torn out of their ability to empathize
and any attempts to talk about that lack
of empathy are met with expressions of
extreme
self-righteousness is there a story we
can tell or method we can apply to heal
that or are we just destined for
increasing violence
and combat
man to be honest i don't see i
right now especially as a social
situation i really don't see things
getting any better
but um i think in your own life
the way to do this is
to remember your sins remember to death
like i said is to always try to find
fault in yourself it's hard to do
but that's what you're supposed to do
because it's easy to find fault in the
other because
we see the outward signs of people like
you know we encounter their outward
signs so we can see those things
so it's better to it's better to to
punch inside you know
mostly
all right
all right father matthew marinelli
father
you're asking me about the situation
with spoons
in the in the greek church in the
orthodox church and communion
and seriously i'm sorry but i'm not
gonna i'm not gonna get into church
politics
it's just it's just too right now it's
just too painful
because there's this there there is a
controversy right now about communion
and whether or not
you should adapt communion to cobid and
uh
and it's just it's it's all very painful
and i will let my i would i would leave
it up to my authority to decide that
all right so james cortez asked i heard
you mentioned two options with regard to
a path
forward out of our current social p
predicament
i gave a solution i'm pretty negative
these days
all right okay so he says first with the
continued resurgence and potential
resurrection of christianity
a new eden and second was build an ark
what is the symbolic significance of the
and how can we conceptualize this idea
for today
what would a modern art possibly
potentially look like
all right i'll give you an example of an
i can't tell you what a modern art would
look like
i'll give you an example of an arc which
was built
uh an arc that was built is is uh
dante's comedy dante's divine comedy
that's an
arc it's an art because
it is a a bundling up together
of all the levels of a reality
within a narrative
that people could actually inhabit
like people people treat dante's comedy
as if
it's describing a spiritual reality that
they can live
and so dante did a great job
so right so who's going to build an ark
today
i don't know
hey jonathan is there a symbolic reason
why the horizontal line
in the crucifix is placed a little
higher
than the middle
i think about that
in general you have to understand that
that there are three horizontal
lines in the cross that there's not just
one there's
there's a there's a headboard or a a
sign
and there's a foot board where the feet
and then there's a transversal which is
the arms and so
those are more important to understand
in terms of understanding
like three levels or you know
the name the identity
you know jesus christ king of the jews
then
the the the body or the hands which are
spread out
the left and the right hand
and then the feet
you know the final connection with the
the ground
that's more important to understand but
i'll think about it in terms of
why why it's higher besides the fact
that
you know the practical aspect of y would
be higher but let's say in terms of
symbolism
i mean a simple way of understanding
could be like a kind of lifting up of
the world
that could be a simple way of
understanding it but i might be
stretching it
i don't like when i'm stretching it
all right guys i think
i think i'm i think i'm done let me just
see
let me just check that let me just check
the super chats and see
i'm running out of steam though
sorry a little off here
really happy the internet was going wild
today i wish i was afraid that it was
gonna
snap off
all right
all right so there aren't too many super
chat so i i will
i'll answer them
all right so cd haroun for five dollars
ask
can the search for the holy grail and
christian sense be compared to the
buddhist awakening
the jewel in lotus or
the islamic story of majnun and laila
i'm afraid that i'm not i don't know
what those stories are i don't know what
the story of majnun and laila
is maybe if i knew if i heard the story
i'd recognize it but i don't know what
it is
and um awakening the jewel into lotus
um
maybe i mean there is there seems the
notion of finding a jewel in a lotus
is definitely something which would be
related to the symbolism of the grail
or in general the symbolism of the pearl
finding the pearl in the in the field
you know
mostly that seems to be related to
something like the uh the jewel in the
lotus
all right and so paul l for 25 no
question thanks paul
and indie visual says a good starter to
the problem of science addressing
consciousness
is found in the first verveiki interview
and more so thank you
individual thanks for pointing that out
and so you can check out
my first interview with paul vander clay
i'm going to be on paul vander clay's
um i'm going to be on paul vander clay's
podcast i think next week or something
so i'm looking forward to that i haven't
talked to him in a while
um there is some talk that i might uh
i don't know if i'll be able to to make
it though on sunday
i uh i put a word out and i might be
participating in a discussion slash
debate
with um with adam friended
and uh paul vander clay and sargon of
akkad i think
and uh was it psa stitch all these
these kind of kind of atheists on the
border line you know
um so anyways if i could make it i think
that would be an interesting
conversation
i guess it would be interesting to talk
to sargon because he's smart
but sometimes you know they're really
it's just so funny to see it's funny
because you see him getting closer
to understanding what religion is about
but he's still like odd i still think
it's silly but i see that without it
we're basically falling apart but it's
silly it's silly it's illegal it's not
for me but
for them you know all the plebs
anyway so it might be interesting to
talk to him um
and so um also those who haven't seen
you know i i've been working for like uh
i've been working for
for like months on um been working for
months
on the idea of this image which would
encapsulate all of the symbolic world
into one image and so i kind of finally
finished it i have it right here i'll
show it to you
i'll show it to you
this last tape on it because because i
was tracing from my pencil drawing
um and so anyways i'm pretty happy that
happened because i've been kind of
thinking about this for like
years i guess and so um anyway so you
can check that out i
i put it out on different different uh
formats
people are interested in that image and
um and so yeah
so guys thanks for thanks for your
attention and i'm sorry if i was a
little
if i was a little convoluted and uh
and not super clear in some of my
answers but you know
so i appreciate everybody's support
thanks for your attention everybody i
wish you the best
and i will talk to you next month all
right bye everybody